thank you
yes
um
if you're wrong
basically
okay
um
is
thank you
sleep
everyone's here
but he's like the stuff
is
like
okay
i wish i could do this
it's cool
did you do that
you yeah tomorrow
there you go
no all right
um
started
you're telling me about your dad
thank you
all right
okay
um
yes
is
people
foreign
yeah yeah
uh
all right
socks
that is
okay
thank you
okay
oh
um
all right
thank you
pleasure
hi everyone good afternoon
all right secretary fudge would have
been impressed with that response
this morning we're all awake a couple of
items for all of you before we get
started
this afternoon the president will take a
virtual tour
of a proterra electric bus and battery
manufacturing plant in greenville south
carolina
he'll be joined by the republican mayor
of greenville knox white
out of greenville knox white is his name
sorry under
underscoring the bipartisan support for
the clean energy infrastructure
investments in the american
jobs plan during the visit today the
president will make three stops around
the manufacturing plant
and speak to employees about different
aspects of the company's
work including battery installation body
assembly and final inspection of the
buses
the american jobs plan includes a total
of 45 billion dollars to accelerate the
adoption of zero emission
transit buses and school buses to
achieve the president's goal for all u.s
made buses to be zero emissions by 2030.
this includes 25 billion for zero
emissions transit vehicles
and 20 billion for electric school buses
there are currently 475 000 yellow
school buses that sounds like a lot to
me
that serve 25 million children and 95
of them are powered by diesel and there
are addition or nearly 85 000
transit vehicles including buses that
still run on diesel
or gas which are linked to asthma and
other health problems that hurt our
community so replacing these buses with
clean technologies
will create good jobs support domestic
manufacturing
tackle a major source of greenhouse gas
emissions and improve the health for
many around
the country also this morning the our
kovad coordinator
jeff zions had his weekly call with
governors
he announced that this week 28 million
doses will go out across
channels with the vast majority going to
jurisdictions
this is consistent with last week's
allocation he also reminded the
governors that there is a significant
amount of vaccine supply
in the system and the federal government
stands ready to help states put shots in
arms as quickly
as possible with that jonathan why don't
you get us started
thank you uh jen just a few minutes ago
the oval office the president spoke
about the trial
of the office president jared tobin he
says quote i'm praying the verdict is
the right brick
he says i think it's quote overwhelming
in my view
uh so i have questions couple questions
on this we could start there
what precisely did the president mean
what is overwhelming
and does this mean the president thinks
the police officer should be convicted
on all accounts
well the president has clearly been
watching the trial closely
as many americans have been uh he was
also
moved by he's moved he was moved by his
conversations with the family yesterday
uh he knows the family and as somebody
who has been
impacted by grief himself that was a
large part of their conversation the
conversation
he had just yesterday as he also noted
the jury is sequestered which is why he
spoke to this but i will
expect that he will weigh in uh more
further
once there is a verdict and i'm not
going to provide additional analysis on
what he meant
you're not able to clarify what is
overwhelming the evidence the case
presented by the prosecution
we're not going to get ahead of the
outcome i expect when there is a verdict
he will have more to say as you as you
say the president made note that he only
spoke out today because the jury was
sequestered
but of course everyone else in
minneapolis and around the country
could hear what he said they'd be in
position to hear what he said today
we know there are worries about unrest
is there not concerned that the
president's words could add to that if
the quote
right verdict is not reached well first
i would say that
regardless of the outcome the president
has consistently called for peace
and our focus as we are working with
state and local authorities
is on providing the space for peaceful
protest
and that will be consistent regardless
of what the outcome
of this uh verdi of the verdict is okay
and then one more on this
uh the judge overseeing the case was
pretty pretty harsh language yesterday
sort of asked politicians to not
weigh in uh on the matter uh
is there concerns now that this the
president's comments could be
grounds for an appeal or even causing a
mistrial
well i i wouldn't i think those were
comments the judge made yesterday again
the jury is sequestered
um which the president also noted in his
comments uh he certainly is not looking
to influence
but he has been touched by the impact on
the family
hence he called the family yesterday and
had that discussion and again i expect
he will weigh in further once there is a
verdict
thank you jen just to follow up the
president has talked about the
importance of an independent
judiciary why is it appropriate for him
to weigh in on the verdict
even though the jury i i wouldn't think
i don't think he would see it as
weighing in on the verdict he was
conveying what many people are feeling
across the country which is compassion
for the family
what a difficult time this is what a
difficult time this is for
many americans across the country who
have been watching this trial
very closely the jury is sequestered uh
that is different
from where things stood just yesterday
and he noted that in his comments as
well
he did call for the right verdict though
um why is it ever appropriate to have
any type of characterization
before the jury has a say especially
again we're going to wait for the jury
to come to their conclusion
and that is when he will have more
extensive remarks
about the outcome this administration
this president has been very clear in
condemning rhetoric that it sees
uh as adding to a
climate of discord is it a double
standard to not condemn or speak out
against the comments by maxine waters
even if she didn't mean
to imply violence well first i would say
that um
the congresswoman has provided further
clarification of her own remarks and i
would certainly point you to that
and if we're looking in this scenario
we're looking at a family
who has lost someone they've just
watched a trial they've seen the video
play
over and over and over again uh families
across the country have watched the
trial
watch the video play over and over again
clearly the impact of trauma
and the exhaustion is on communities of
color around the country more than it is
on
others and the president recognizes this
is an extremely painful issue
and of course you know sympathize us
with everyone who feels the grief of
george floyd's passing
as well as the killings of so many other
people of color at the hands of law
enforcement
and you know i think having a
conversation with his family yesterday
uh you know as someone who has been
through trauma himself uh that was a big
part of their conversation as i
i believe george floyd's brother also
conveyed uh you know you feel it you
feel it deeply in your heart and i think
that his comments were a reflection of
that
and very quickly i know there is a lot
of focus on trying to get the george
floyd legislation passed to the senate
it's passed through the house
where does that stand and will the
president move that effort
up in terms of his list of priorities
particularly as he approaches his 100th
day in office
well first i would say that um
addressing uh
policing across the country addressing
what he feel
racial injustice what he feels is one of
the four major crises we're facing as a
country
continues to be a top priority for the
president and
certainly uh moving the george floyd
bill forward uh through the senate
the president would be eager to have
that happen and eager to sign that bill
into law
and uh he is not only kept abreast of it
uh he remains engaged in it with his
team here and also
directly welcome back to chris clinton
you may ask for an update on the present
school to reopen schools this is goal
still by the end of this month to have
majority of kid aid schools open at
least one day
a week and if so do you think you'll hit
that goal and to what extent is the
administration worried
by some of the more recent outbreaks
you've seen among older age students
tied
to these variants of the virus sure well
our goal remains to have
uh the majority of schools open five
days a week uh and
that is certainly something that is
being led that effort by our secretary
of education
uh and uh they've been providing regular
updates there's numbers that we look at
on a month-to-month basis
we remain confident we can reach that
goal they're also
because of the cdc steps that they put
out publicly
seems like months ago maybe weeks ago is
more accurate to say
we know that those measures are
effective and they can help mitigate
risk in schools
and our department of education and also
uh
of course is looking is working very
closely with schools on implementing
those and ensuring kids can be safe but
we remain confident about our
path to reaching that goal you're
pleased with the progress so far
to what extent you're concerned that
rolling closures are going to drag into
the fall this is a core promise of the
president to get schools open where he
can
absolutely and it remains a core promise
it remains something that his secretary
of education is
leading the effort on i think the last
data we've seen
was from february i believe because of
the reporting
requirements which showed that there was
an increased number of schools that had
were open and also an increased number
of schools that were open five days a
week and so we feel we're on the right
track
and these mitigation measures including
wearing masks
including taking steps to provide social
distancing opportunities
the money that's going out the door to
schools and school districts that need
that assistance
are going to help us continue to make
progress and with regards to your
comment around
the call with governors today as you
know of course the the production of j
j has been relying on that one plant in
baltimore coming up
the jnj is now no longer citing its goal
of delivering 100 million doses by the
end of june they're saying they'll say
deliver 100 million but they're not
saying when how does this impact the
president's goal of course it was the
availability of those shots that led him
to say that every american who would be
enough shot for every american by the
end of may
what is his current goal do you think
that that plan will be online soon turn
the fda is involved in it
well of course that's going to work with
the second part of your question of
course it's going to require fda
approval as you know there's a meeting
on friday to determine
what's next as it relates to j j and
hopefully we'll learn more then
we'll see but our goal we remain uh
confident in our ability to meet the
needs
that we feel will be out there in the
public by the end of may and we will
have enough
vaccine for every american but by the
end of july
without jnj that is based on the supply
that we've ordered from modern
and pfizer and pfizer as i know you've
probably seen has also announced that
they are going to work on
expediting their own manufacturing and
delivery of their vaccine so we are
confident we'll be able to meet the
demand in the public
now every american over 16 is eligible
to
receive the vaccine and our focus is on
encouraging continuing to encourage
people to get shots in their arms
sorry one other quick one there was a
report yesterday in the journal that
uh the administration is considering
reducing the amount of nicotine that can
be in cigarettes
uh and also restricting or banning
menthol cigarettes altogether
is that something you can update us on
about whether the administration favors
either of these positions
i don't i have seen the report of course
i don't have any policy previews
proposals to preview today we will
review a range of policy options in line
with the president's public health goals
but to reiterate there are no policy
proposals or decisions
uh to review today uh go ahead thank you
jen one more question about the comments
from congresswoman waters the house
manual leader kevin mccarthy is accusing
her of inciting violence and then he had
the judge yesterday calling her words of
warrant
and saying that she was being
disrespectful of the rule of law i just
want to be very clear here does the
white house
condone the congresswoman's comments
well first i would say again that the
congresswoman
clarified her own comments and what i
can do is speak for the president's view
which is that it's important to provide
a space and an opportunity for peaceful
protest but protesting should be
peaceful that's something he has
consistently advocated for
and he will regardless of the outcome of
the trial she was
calling on some protesters to perhaps
get more confrontation and she's had
additional comments since then right
yes okay she has which
provide additional clarification so i
guess my question is does white house
believe that those kinds of comments
are helpful in the middle of this trial
that everybody knows
uh could lead to more violence and
unrest well again i can speak to what
the president's point of view is
which is that it's important to provide
an opportunity for peaceful protest
that's what he's continued to advocate
for what he's consistently advocated for
but i would also say that when somebody
provides a clarification for their
comments
that's an important context to include
in anybody's reporting
i'd also like to ask the question about
uh since this is we're 20.
senator chuck schumer said from the
senate floor he called it the unofficial
american marijuana holiday and he said
that he now supports
legalizing marijuana on a national level
is this something that
president biden would support well the
president supports leaving decisions
regarding legalization for recreational
use up to the states
rescheduling cannabis as a schedule two
drugs so researchers can study its
positive
and negative impacts and at the federal
level he supports decriminalizing
marijuana
use and automatically expunging any
prior criminal
records he also supports legalizing
medicinal marijuana so that's his point
of view on the issue so if the housing
tasks
house and senate pass a bill legalizing
marijuana at a federal level would the
president sign it
uh well i just have outlined what his
position is which isn't the same as what
the house and senate have proposed but
they have not yet passed a bill
uh go ahead okay one final question if i
could
uh some people in prison on marijuana
charges are asking president biden to
keep
his campaign promise and release them
where is president biden on keeping that
campaign promise
well i think when i'm talking about
reschedule rescheduling cannabis as a
schedule
to drug so regis that is also going to
have an impact on
the uh criminal justice system as well
um go ahead
thanks john um it's clear the dividing
lines on the uh
traditional infrastructure portions of
the president's job and infrastructure
package of the paid force
and the president says he's willing to
open a compromise republicans seem
willing to support
new higher new and higher user fees
on for americans to use roads bridges
and airports uh but the president has
insisted that
such fees violate his campaign pledge
not to raise taxes
on americans earning less than four
hundred thousand um
is the president's idea of compromise
just adjusting the corporate tax rate
or is he willing to budge on these user
fees well first the president's pledge
which he you touched on
which he outlined on the campaign has
reiterated since that he's not going to
raise
taxes on people making over four hundred
thousand dollars a year
uh he's not going to budge on that
pledge uh so that is a
line in the sand for him but this
package and this proposal is really
about
creating millions of jobs it's about
investing in and modernizing our
nation's infrastructure
it's about ensuring that caregivers have
the support they need it's about
providing broadband access to americans
across the country and leveling the
playing field
that's what the discussion should be
about he believes it should be paid for
and there are really two options
either you uh put the put the burden on
the backs of corporations that can
afford to pay more
or you put the burden on the backs of
the american people he's happy to have a
debate about that particular issue
cool um democratic lawmakers are called
on the body administration to scrutinize
potential back
bank mergers more aggressively arguing
the justice department
has approved too many leading to hire
fees for consumers
and reduce access is the white house
looking at this issue and does it share
those lawmakers comment concern uh we've
certainly seen the comments and the
president supports competitive markets
and thinks robust competition is good
for consumers and for innovation
he has appointed and will continue to
appoint highly qualified people who are
focused on vigorously enforcing our
anti-trust
laws that's his one of his objectives he
looks at of course the department of
justice was which handles these mergers
in collaboration with the banking
agencies are probably the right sources
to look to for additional
content or comment sure and last
question there have been at least three
fatal crashes attributed to
u.s tesla drivers using autopilots the
ntsb has urged regulators to be more
aggressive
and overseeing that technology
is the white house engaged on this issue
and do they share the opinion
of the ntsb well i know the department
of transportation as you noted is
aware of these incidents involving tesla
vehicles and that the national highway
trans
traffic safety administration otherwise
known as
uh well nitsa immediately launched a
special crash investigation team to
investigate
the crash um they're actively engaged
with local law enforcement
and tesla to learn more about the
details of the crash and will take
appropriate steps
when they have more information and of
course they remain in touch as
appropriate with
uh our teams on the ground teams and
sure but does the white house have any
concerns or anything specific
well it's appropriate for it to be
handled through nitsa and ntsb so that's
where it's being handled
good caitlin thank you yesterday you
said the white house did not want to get
ahead of the jury's deliberations but of
course the jury is still deliberating
so what changed well the jury is now
sequestered
which is a significant change and
certainly we want to allow them
space and time to consider and make a
decision about what they believe the
verdict should be
does the president still feel that he
can come out after the verdict
and regardless of what it is tell people
to accept it given he's weighed in on
what he thinks the verdict should be
well again i think anybody who's been
watching the president and you guys are
probably
tired of me saying that his position is
that
he believes there should be space for
peaceful protest he's been consistent in
that that will be his point of view
regardless of the outcome that is what
we've been communicating
publicly but also locally to mayors to
governors
uh to local law enforcement as we're
communicating
in preparation so uh that's consistently
been his view and
uh he'll continue to advocate that
regardless of the outcome and so what
made him want to weigh in today on this
before the verdict has come down well i
think he was asked a question if i if i
if i followed it closely um
but i asked him what his message was was
for the floyd family not what his
what he thought the verdict should be
well i think caitlyn you know he
obviously has been following this trial
quite closely as many americans
have been he has been was obviously
impacted by
his conversation with the floyd family
yesterday as somebody who has
lived through loss and trauma himself
and he certainly
uh has his mind and his heart on on what
is happening around the country as
people are digesting
and watching these videos and watching
this trial go forward
so he knows that the um jury is
sequestered as he noted in his comments
which is certainly a different place
from where it was yesterday
and who is he consulting with about what
his response should be after the verdict
does come down i know we talked about
speaking with state officials and local
authorities but who is
one of his advisors that he's speaking
with about the right way to respond to
the verdict
regardless of what it is no i think
that's something that will come from the
president's heart and he will
be prepared to speak to it in some form
or another i don't want to get ahead of
what that format will look like
um when we know what the verdict looks
like okay and my last question
the u.s ambassador to russia is now
coming home from
consultation of course amid a pretty
tense week with
russia is he going to be meeting with
the president and
can you confirm that yes he will be
going back to russia
yeah that is absolutely the intention
he's returning home this week to visit
his family he hasn't been home in about
a year i believe
meet with members of the new
administration with whom he's not had a
chance to consult with since he
agreed to continue serving in his post
and he'll return to moscow soon does
that include
a meeting with the president though i
don't i'm not i'm not aware of that
being on the schedule
um but it's primarily to meet with new
members of the team as the
administration is turned over and
there's new personnel at the state
department on the national security team
etc uh go ahead uh yes so the president
spoke with the floyd family yesterday he
talked about the trial today what does
he see as his role
or responsibility as president during
these deliberations and then
perhaps as a verdict comes down well i
think one the president
um as i've noted a little bit in
response to some earlier questions is
certainly
uh was touched by and impacted by his
conversation with the floyd family
yesterday he met with him last year it's
a family
uh he feels he knows a little bit and
he's somebody who has
been through trauma and lost himself and
so
if you put all the politics aside and
all the
everything else that's something that is
an immediate
unfortunate bond between people who have
lost family members
he also understands this is an extremely
painful moment
for many people in this country who are
exhausted
who are tired of seeing one
person after another um lose their life
at the hands of law enforcement he's
he's aware of that and the need for
reform so i would say
um you know i'm not going to get ahead
of what the outcome is or what the
verdict does and i would expect
you'll hear some comment from the
president i don't know what format that
will look like we'll have to see what
the verdict
is uh once uh that isn't that the it is
concluded the jury has made the decision
and that is concluded um and we'll see
what his role is moving forward
he'll continue to call for calm okay and
what does the the white house's goals
for the climate summit
uh later this week sure and uh were they
pleased to hear that vladimir putin
would be
speaking at it well we invited him to
attend as we did 39 other
global leaders um so i would say first
we're gonna have a
call uh briefing call later this evening
to give you all a better rundown of the
schedule
the speaking uh and what is planned for
speaking
uh at the summit so i know there's been
kind of a mix of reporting out there
but we'll give you more of a full
rundown later this evening
but the president's goal is really to
convene the world's major economies
and other key voices to galvanize
efforts to keep the vital goal
of limiting warming to 1.5 degrees
celsius celsius within
reach and we know we have had some
backstep on that which the united states
has been certainly a part of over the
last couple of years
we have a role to play he'll certainly
talk more about that but
during the summit leaders will discuss
mobilizing public and private sector
financing to drive the net zero
transition and to help vulnerable
countries cope with climate impacts
obviously
world's largest economies as you all
know uh have have a
sometimes greater responsibility for
themselves but also in for some
other economies that are not as
economically advanced in helping address
these issues uh and he'll also talk
about it's an opportunity to also talk
about the economic benefits of climate
action
with a strong emphasis on jobbation and
the importance of ensuring
all communities and workers benefit from
this transition so that's
he'll be talking about that but it's
really an opportunity in a forum
to talk about how as a global community
uh we can all come together to address
what he sees as one of the four crises
of his presidency
is putin's involvement important given
the tensions
between the two nations right now well i
think it's important for any
large economy and developed nation to
participate in a climate summit because
the world's largest emitters are
off also for the most part aligned with
the world's largest
economies or the most populated
countries and so
hence those are the people who are
invited and it just sends a message
about
the recognition that addressing the
climate is addressing the climate crisis
is something that even when you have
agreement disagreements about other
areas you can
we can agree on that we know xi jinping
will participate as well
i believe that almost every leader who
was invited is attending but
they'll give you more of a rundown of
that later this evening and a more
detailed rundown of the speaking program
as well
sure go ahead thanks jen you just
suggested that the format that the
president's remarks
would take after the chauvin trial could
depend on the outcome of the trial
the president hasn't delivered a speech
yet though on race relations
or policing so why not and why wouldn't
immediately
after this trial regardless of what the
outcome is be the time for him to do
that
well first i would say again that
addressing
um race relations and improving
uh equity in this country is central to
his presidency and central to his focus
every day
and his actions his policies certainly
play that out uh i'm not going to get
ahead of what
the outcome of the trial will be and i'm
cert
i'm just attempting to set an
expectation about
uh that that will decide what's
appropriate
and what the country needs to hear once
we know the verdict and once we see
the outcome he also said that he had
been engaged directly
on policing reform legislation has the
president picked up the phone and called
any senate republicans such as
republican senator tim scott about
policing reform legislation
i don't have any calls to read out for
you but i can tell you that in his
conversations with democrats and
republicans and he's spoken with many of
both
he talks about a range of issues i'll
also say that
a lot of the work on the george floyd
act is happening on the hill
and the negotiations between members of
the senate you reference senator scott
obviously senator booker is playing a
vital role
they're going to have to work together
with other members of the house to
determine
where there can be agreement and what an
outcome can look like and if they can
come to agreement on that
that's the status the president would
love to have a bill come to his desk so
he can sign it into law well last summer
policing legislation stalled because
they couldn't come to a consensus on
issues like qualified immunity
no knock warrants as well as bans on
chokeholds
so what is the president's position on
qualified immunity
and does he think that democrats should
agree to pass legislation that perhaps
doesn't
fan no knock warrants or ban chokeholds
but would restrict their use in some
capacity such as limiting federal
funding
or something like that in order to get
republican support for that bill and get
a bill passed in law
well we're going to allow democrats and
republicans in the senate to
negotiate amongst themselves about what
they think a final outcome or a final
agreement
could be and we're certainly hopeful
that they'll make progress in that and
the president is eager to sign
policing reform legislation into law and
certainly we recognize that stalled last
year there's been work
since then and we're hopeful that the
president will be able to sign a law
i can tell you that there are a number
of steps that he has taken
that he can take as uh president and his
department of justice can take and
during hit the campaign he emphasized
the importance of the department of
justice using the authority
he spearheaded as a senator to
investigate systemic police misconduct
that doesn't have to wait
for congress to act and last week
attorney general garland reversed a
trump administration
memo that limited the use of consent
decrees with respect to investigation of
police departments
the president also pledged to appoint
doj leadership that would prioritize
pattern or practice investigations
he has two critical nominees pending who
would do exactly that anita gupta and
kristen clarke
uh he of course supports as i already
noted the george floyd act
uh he's also called in his initial
budget for increasing funding for the
department of justice's
civil rights division by millions of
dollars in order to advance
accountability
and reform for abusive police practices
and finally multiple states have taken
action is it enough no it's not enough
he wants to sign federal legislation
into law but his own administration has
taken steps
even while that legislation is working
through the negotiations that happen in
congress
you have and i know you need to move on
but can you share with us what the
president's position is
on qualified immunity no knock warrants
or chokeholds
i don't have anything new to share with
you from what he said on the campaign
trail i'm happy to provide that after
i'm sure you're familiar with his
please go ahead hi thanks john um
following up a little bit on a question
earlier um president biden still opposes
the legalization of marijuana um
you outline what he does support but why
does he still oppose taking this step at
this point
public following indicates about
two-thirds of americans support
legalizing
not the senator and his party obviously
is pushing for it
uh huge numbers of elected democrats
many more states
are pushing forward with marijuana
legalization why is he reluctant to sort
of
take that final step and support
legalization well
as you know from covering this um
rescheduling cannabis as a schedule two
drug would allow for research
researchers to study its positive and
negative effects
he wants to look at that he of course
supports decriminalizing marijuana use
he supports leaving decisions up to the
states
and he supports legalizing medicinal
marijuana uh but he'll look at the
research uh once that's concluded but
right now he's still reluctant to why is
he so reluctant to
support legalization despite the
movement that's happening
towards it well he of course we
understand the movement that's happening
toward it um i'm speaking for what his
position is and what's
long consistently been his position uh
he wants to decriminalize but
again he'll look at the research uh of
the positive and negative impacts
and then on a related note yesterday the
house passed
uh the safe banking act which is meant
to stay toward cannabis
is legal let businesses use the banking
system
uh legally um there i noticed that bill
passed
with a very big bipartisan majority half
of the republicans support it
um there was no statement of
administration policy on that bill does
the president support it
it's a good question kevin i'll have to
check on it and we'll get you a comment
after the briefing
go ahead thanks jen uh on refugee policy
you were asked on april 1st
about why refugee flights hadn't
continued
and the president not raising cash on
refugees and you're asked
whether it had anything to do with the
situation on the border she said quote
no no it's not related to that now but
the president referenced the border
directly
his explanation of the weekend you
mentioned it yesterday so how do you
square
those two explanations previously saying
the border was not a factor
and then now saying that it is well let
me walk you back a little bit to the
last few months um i i will do this
briefly i promise josh's eyes are
glazing over here as he's
i'm just kidding he's worried how long
i'm going to talk here um
i'll first say during the transition um
sean we
obviously we took a look at um how uh
what had happened over the last few
years and how we could set a more
aspirational
larger goal uh of so we could welcome
more
refugees into the country and we set a
big aspirational goal which we remain
committed to which is
uh welcoming in 125 000 refugees uh by
the end
of the fiscal year next year um and the
president announced that and he
announced that we want to
get to we want a down payment on that i
should say 62.5
uh thousand by the end of this fiscal
year now a couple things have happened
in the last several weeks and
some of that was happening deep in the
policy wells and
uh sometimes it takes some time for that
to be communicated
more broadly within the administration
including the fact that the
um you know the impact on or the office
of refugee resettlement
of having of course welcoming in
delivering on a decision the president
made to
treat children as they come across the
border humanely and ensure they
are treated in a safe manner has a has a
way on
the system including the office of
refugee resettlement
including personnel and including uh
funding that is a factor but that some
of that decision making is
is happening and kind of uh people you
know at the office of refugee
resettlement uh
in ways that maybe you know i wasn't
communicated to
about it at that time but it happened
over the last couple of weeks
um and in that time i should say this
month so just this month
uh so recently probably since i made
those comments hhs transferred 850
million from the public health and
social services emergency fund
and 287 million from apartmental
accounts the unaccompanied children
program in order to ensure
we can uh treat kids with humanity and
ensure
they're safe these transfers were made
using the hhs secretary standing
transfer authority
and have no impact necessarily on the
refugee program but it's funding
from the of the same office and the
president's responsibility
is to look across government look across
resources
uh and his team is and see where there
is a
capacity and where resource assessments
need to be made
so are you saying that the border has
emerged as a factor in the last 20 days
i mean even before april first we're
already seeing an increase
the number of migrants arriving at the
border and the strains it was presenting
to the system
are you saying the border was not a
factor back then at all in
thinking about refugee policy let me
bring you behind the curtains of how
policy making works
um you assess over time uh and you look
over time at
uh your systems your resources your
processes
uh what what changes need to be made
within government to address
issues as they're arising and certainly
we've seen of course there's been a
number of unaccompanied children and
need to reopen shelters or open shelters
across the country
taking care of children and doing it in
humane way um
is uh costs money um and that's
something that has certainly
had an impact but a big part of um
as we've looked at um and assessed
challenges here
uh the primary obstacle to reaching the
goal has been the decimation of the
refugee admission program under the
prior administration and as you know
there's there is part when refugees
arrive and they are
resettled and provided benefits by the
uh by orr
there is also the um vetting process
that takes place
and through our state department this
was all
decimated under the last administration
and we had to make an assessment of that
as well
that happens over a progressive period
of time there's not a magic day when you
wake up
and you and an alarm bell goes off you
have to assess over time what the needs
are and make changes as needed
real quick uh why did you guys identify
may 15th as sort of the horizon for when
you would announce a new cap on
uh i expect it will actually be sooner
than that
um and we were always going to be
assessing uh what
uh what our resources our capacity would
allow for
and uh i bet i expect it will be before
may 15th it's approximately a month
from last take a target of my always
unraised over
eyes and just follow up on this issue
it's an important issue but why not just
raise the cap to your promise the cap is
just that it's a cap it's not a
guarantee you're not requiring that
number of people
to come in through the program why keep
the cap lower you know back off this
promise progressives of course who are
skeptical of this
president early on through the primary
they're saying that this is a broken
promise arguably his first big one of
his administration
well first we're actually going to set a
cap an a a large cap
soon uh and i expect it's going to be
before may 15th
but uh you know i think we wanted to
you're right in the sense that the
cap is just a number most often times
throughout history you don't reach the
cap the cap is just a number we could
set the cap at a hundred thousand or a
million
it doesn't really we're trying to send a
message to the world
uh that we want to welcome in refugees
and that's who we are as an
administration
hence we wanted to provide greater
clarity for what our overall objectives
were even if they weren't digested
initially on friday um you know i would
say that
one will set that cap two we wanted to
assess given the impacts of
the decimation of the refugee admissions
program the need to
move some resources around what's
possible what was possible but
we do want to set a large cap we do want
to send a message to the world that
we remain committed to our objective
we've always been committed to the
objective and the goal of 125 000 by
next fiscal year is really a question of
how close we could get and what kind of
down payment we could do this year
uh go in the back thank you jen so just
a quick clarification
and the president said quote it's
overwhelming uh a few hours ago in the
oval office
even the evidence against derek chovin
was overwhelming
i think i've answered this question a
couple of times
okay um go ahead you have another
question i do um
still the same topic but as far as a
response to the verdict
shows the trip to minneapolis on the
table and would you consider joining a
demonstration
well i don't we're not going to get
ahead of what the outcome or the verdict
is
and we'll make an evaluation about what
the country needs
at that point in time uh go in the back
hi so i know you just in some ways
answered the question about why but i'm
i'm confused about why you won't clarify
what the president said about
the praying the verdict is right and it
being overwhelming
the president obviously volunteered this
information no one asked him for his
opinion about
the verdict why not say this is what the
president meant
william i think um you know our
objective is to
um lead the president was obviously
clearly impacted
by his conversation with the floyds uh
the floyd family just yesterday
uh he obviously has spoken to uh
the video the trial uh the events of
last year uh when they happened at the
time
uh and he is uh impacted by the
exhaustion and the trauma that he's seen
across the country uh over the last
several weeks um
i think it was a reflection of that but
again we're not trying to provide
greater information about predictions of
a verdict
we want to leave that to the jury to
make that determination
they're sequestered so they obviously
can't hear or listen to anything
being said uh but i just i'm not gonna
have more clarification for you
simply is it wrong for americans to see
this as the president saying he hopes
the officers
gonna be found guilty and that evidence
is overwhelming when people see that
quote is it wrong for them to
make that assumption that that's what
the president's saying i think what
people should conclude is that the
president like many americans
uh has been deeply impacted by the trial
he's been deeply impacted by he was
deeply impacted by his conversation
with the floyd family yesterday that he
understands that people are exhausted
that they are tired that this type of
violence and trauma we've seen around
the country and continue to see over the
past
couple of weeks and hopefully that's
what they take away from his comments
apart from what the verdict might be i
wonder if you could speak a little bit
to
americans who fell on edge especially
african americans who've seen
so many verdicts so many trials happen
no matter whatever the outcome is i
wonder if the white house has a message
for people just feeling anxious about
what comes after this verdict
well um you know first i would say that
um
you know the president um sees their
pain
and understands or and tries to
understand
uh the trauma that people have been
through across the country and he's
watching the trial
closely and i think he would want people
to know that um
he's working hard at making change
possible
and i can walk through some of the steps
that has been taken by his department of
justice
he would love to sign the george floyd
bill uh into law
and that he also is here as a human
being and he
sees their pain he recognizes their loss
and their trauma and he wants to put
reforms in place to
help address it moving forward and
speaker nancy pelosi came to the defense
of representative waters
representative waters as you said
clarified she said my actual words
don't matter i wonder why the white
house isn't also coming to the defense
of representative waters given
the fact that she's now facing an
onslaught of attacks especially but i
would say republicans i wonder why the
white house isn't saying
we back what said about being
confrontational she was obviously not
threatening violence there are civil
rights leaders they're saying that's
what
that's what civil rights is to be
confrontational to be active well she
could she also clarified her own remarks
amish and i think that's the most
powerful piece to point to
the arizona governor he um he lifted the
mass mandate
on all public schools in that state i
wonder what the white house makes of
that that the president supported does
he want to see other states do that
or maybe does he not like the idea that
that happened uh well we certainly
recommend any state
and governor follow public health
guidelines and masking
and social distancing or masking
specifically since you asked about it is
one of the clear steps that can be an
effective mitigation measure according
to the cdc
even as we've seen variants and even as
we've seen
upticks in some parts of the country so
certainly it wouldn't be a step that
we would support go ahead on the climate
summit
will there be any kind of joint
statement
at the end of the summit also will there
be any bilateral meetings during the
summit there won't be any bilateral
meetings um
the summit um uh but in terms of a joint
statement at the end i don't have a
prediction of that i expect you'll
all learn more on the call later this
evening
also during the meeting between
president biden
and prime minister suga last friday did
they talk about the fukushima wastewater
issue or what's the present view on this
issue
i believe uh we are having our team stay
in touch and look at it i don't think
that
the the steps are happening for a few
years if i'm getting this correct or a
few months um
but i i would have to check with our
national security team and see if it was
a point of discussion
go ahead scott thank you um so another
question about today's unofficial
holiday which i think some of our
colleagues are potentially celebrating
um
so as you might remember one of
president trump's final actions in
office was to grant clemency
to a dozen people in federal prison who
are being held on marijuana charges but
there still remain a lot more in federal
prison on marijuana charges including
luke skarmatso who
was sentenced to 22 years in prison for
operating a legal medical marijuana
business in california
given as you've noted in the briefing
the president's support for
decriminalization support for expunging
exactly these types of defenses
is are there any plans to revisit some
of those bids for clemency
maybe in honor of the holiday well i
would just take it as an opportunity to
reiterate that the president uh supports
legalizing medicinal marijuana uh it
sounds like it's applicable and this or
would have been applicable
in this case um and of course
decriminalizing marijuana use and
automatically expunging any prior
criminal records in terms of individual
cases i can't get ahead of those
obviously i'd
have to i i don't expect we would just
to expectation set
i'm happy to see if there's anything
more from our council's office we could
share thank you
thank you everyone thank you
you